the federal minimum wage hasn't gone up
since 2009 it's seven dollars and
twenty-five cents an hour but some
states and cities have raised wages
locally this week Los Angeles followed
in Seattle and San Francisco's footsteps
raising its minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour that'll happen by 2020
corporations are also taking this matter
into their own hands a few months ago
gap announced that 65,000 of its workers
will see their pay go up and it's not
the only retailer to have done this big
box stores are also paying their workers
a bit more Walmart announced that all
new workers will make at least nine
dollars an hour in 2015 and that's going
to go up to ten dollars an hour next
year we learned this week that that
dragged down Walmart's earnings last
quarter but executives say they've done
the cost-benefit analysis this is
actually going to help Walmart in the
long run you see there are two reasons
for that one is companies are having to
work harder to attract workers and to
keep workers because the economy has
gotten better the other is they're
facing mounting pressure a few months
ago there was a big campaign to raise
wages in the fast food sector to fifteen
dollars an hour well starting on July
first the average hourly wage for new
worker McDonald's will be nine dollars
and ninety cents there is a catch to
that however that's only going to happen
at McDonald's restaurants that are owned
by mcdonald's and most mcdonald's are
owned by franchisees so this is really
going to affect workers at about ten
percent of mcdonald's locations in the
u.s. a single person is considered poor
if he makes eleven thousand seven
hundred dollars or less a family of four
is considered below the poverty line at
household income is twenty four thousand
two hundred fifty dollars or less so
what would someone living below the
poverty line have to make to get out of
poverty well there's a lot of complexity
to that question geography is one thing
size of household but according to Ken
Jacobs who's a labor economist at the
University of California Berkeley a
single mother with one kid working 30
hours a week we need to make thirteen
dollars and twelve cents an hour